[Music]
okay I'm ready the recently released
census report on poverty in 2017 shows
some positive developments the official
poverty rate declined from twelve point
seven to twelve point three percent
meaning that almost a million fewer
Americans were in poverty last year than
the year before
income from earnings increased which
helped minority groups reached their
lowest poverty rates ever but a word of
caution we shouldn't put too much stock
in the official poverty rate because it
doesn't count many of the tax and
transfer programs that help low-income
Americans to see how well the u.s. is
doing in fighting material deprivation
you should pay more attention to
consumption poverty a metric that tells
us what low-income Americans have and
can afford one way in which the official
poverty rate is helpful though is it
tells us how many Americans say they are
earning their way out of poverty through
work small decline like we saw is
definitely a good thing but it's not
enough let's hope we see more Americans
working and earning their way out of
poverty in the 2018 data what do you
think about the way we measure poverty
in the United States let us know in your
comments and also let us know what other
topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more research and videos
from a